[Music]  jerax possitive digging as deep as he  did was one in which we wanted to  support once he was on the set his voice  changed and he only spoke as mr. Jack  conducted himself as mr. J you really  couldn't connect with him unless you  called him J mr. J Joker and you know it  creates an interesting set dynamic when  somebody does that I would go into his  trailer and have a conversation with him  and I remember the first time that  happened I was pausing because I  realized I was actually having a  conversation with mr. J and not  necessarily Jared that's right well I  was in another world I was in another  universe it's exactly where I needed to  be and it was an incredible experiment  incredible exercise so you know  disappearing going into that rabbit hole  was something I never expected continued  my friend I ever really  [Music]  you